in the last video we figured out the the
formulas for the observed period and
frequency for an observer sitting in the
path of the source so the source is
moving towards the user observer so this
is ik this is the example where the
train is moving towards you and you
perceive the trains horn as having a
higher pitch or a higher frequency and
we're able to do that by just kind of
doing a thought experiment saying okay
my my object starts here after one
period a period is just a measure of
time but it's the measure of time over
which the source emits a cycle so it
emits a cycle every period but after one
period we said okay where is that first
wavefront or that first pulse or that
first crest
and where is the source because it only
exactly one period has passed by and the
source will be ready to emit another
crest or another cycle so the distance
between where the source is and that
kind of the front of the crest of that
first crest that is going to be the
wavelength because this next thing that
emits is going to be traveling at the
exact same velocity and there's going to
be separated by that distance which we
saw is this expression we said how long
will it take it to travel that distance
well it's traveling at a speed of V sub
W that'll tell you what the observed
period would be for this dude over here
we calculated right here and then the
observed frequency is just the inverse
of that now let's think about the
situation where the observer is over
here the observer is over here so so
this these equations or these formulas
that we came up right here this is
observer observer or let me say source
travelling in direction of the absorb of
observer source traveling traveling in
observers observers direction now let's
think about the opposite case where the
source is traveling away from the
observer and that's in this case the
observer is that guy over there maybe
I'll do it in a different color he'll be
blue so this is the observer so when we
started off our source was right here
after exactly one period from the
sources point of view the first that
first crest emitted has traveled
radially outward that
our this is the distance the velocity of
the wave times the amount of time that's
passed use velocity times time is going
to give you a distance and where the
source of the wave will have traveled to
the right exactly this distance it's
velocity times the amount of time that's
gone by now in the last video we said
okay this guy
that wave is just passing this guy how
long will take for that pulse that's
being emitted right then to also reach
them and then that tells us the period
between two pulses or between two crests
and I'll think about that exact same
situation here that first crest is just
passing this guy and a period of or the
T sub s which is a period of the emitted
wave has just passed by so this guy is
just about to emit another way so that
other wave is going to be right here so
what is the distance between the crest
or the cycle or however you want to
think about the pulse that is passing
him by right now what is the distance
between that and the pulse the front
edge of that pulse that is emitting
being emitted right at that moment right
at that moment well it's going to be
this radius which is this value it'll be
V sub W times the period that is that
distance plus the amount of distance
that our source has traveled away from
this guy so plus V sub s times the
period so that's what this distance is
and this is how far apart this wave
pulse is going to be from that one or if
this crest is going to be from that one
so if he's seeing this this first crest
right now right at this moment how long
will it take him to see the crest that's
being emitted right now that's B that's
this far away from him
well it's that far away from him so let
me write this down so it'll take so the
amount of time it takes for him to see
the next crest or the next the same
point in the next cycle that's the
period that's the observed period that's
going to be equal to this distance the
velocity of the wave times the period
from the perspective of the source plus
the velocity of the source because the
source has gotten that much further away
from him velocity of the source times
the period of the source so
that's how far the next crest is and
then you divide it by the speed of the
wave by the speed of each of the crest
which is just the velocity of the wave
and we can just factor out the T sub s
is here and say this is T sub s times V
sub W the velocity of the wave plus the
velocity of the source divided by the
velocity of the wave so this will be a
larger observed period than if this guy
was stationary and especially if then if
the observer was in the path of the guy
that makes sense because every time this
guy issues a cycle he is moving a little
bit further away so every crest or every
the same point in the cycle is going to
be further and further apart you're
going to have longer wavelengths longer
periods and if you want the observed
frequency for that guy over there I'll
do it in the same color the observed
frequency for a guy where the source is
traveling away from him is just the
inverse of that so one over the period
one over the period say market we did
there one over the period from the from
the point of view of the source is the
frequency of the source
we've color-coded that is so one over T
sub s is equal to the frequency of the
source this is the inverse of that so
I'm just taking 1 over everything here
so 1 over T sub s is the frequency of
the source and then we take the inverse
of this over here the velocity of the
wave divided by the velocity of the wave
plus the velocity of the source so we're
done at least for the simple cases
obviously it becomes a little more
interesting when someone isn't exactly
in the direction of the source or
exactly being moved away from but these
are kind of the two extreme cases so
this is when this is the situation when
it is moving away from you and just to
check our math and maybe make it a
little bit concrete in relation to the
video we did to what we introduced the
idea of the Doppler effect let's
actually apply those numbers so in that
video two videos ago we had a situation
where the velocity of our source was 5
meters per second to the right and the
velocity of the wave was 10 meters per
second outward radially outward and the
period of our wave
call it the period of our let me do
another color the period of our from the
point of view of the source was one was
one second per cycle and the frequency
was just the inverse of that so one
cycle per second or one Hertz which is
just a cycle per second so using those
numbers let's see if we get to the exact
same answer we got in that first video
where we first learned about the Doppler
effect so let's look at the frequency
from the point of view of this gentleman
right here so the frequency of the
source is going to be one one cycle per
second one Hertz the velocity of the
wave is 10 meters per second let me
write this 1 cycle per second velocity
wave is 10 meters per second the
velocity of the wave is 10 meters per
second minus the velocity of the source
is 5 meters per second so that what's
this going to be equal to the observed
frequency for this guy right there the
observed frequency for that guy right
there's going to be one cycle per second
times you have 10 over 10 minus 5 and
the and and the meters per second cancel
out meters per second the numerator
meters per second the denominator so 10
divided by 10 minus 5 or 10 divided by 5
is going to be 2 so it's going to be 2
cycles per second 2 cycles per second
and if you want the period the observed
period for this guy it's going to be the
inverse of that or it's going to be 1/2
seconds per cycle and this is exactly
what we got in the previous video or
actually those two videos ago now what
about the guy who's this guy is running
away from well do the exact same thing
you have one cycle per second or one
Hertz that's the emitted frequency from
the point of view of the source times
the velocity of the wave divided by the
velocity of the wave plus the velocity
of the source because moving away from
him so it's 10 over 10 plus 5 that's 10
over 15 that is 2/3 so this is equal to
2/3 the units over here I'll cancel out
this was cycles per second so 2/3 cycle
per second which
confirms the numbers we got in that
first video so that should make us feel
good and it also makes a lot of sense
this guy is going to see the wave each
each crest more frequently he's going to
observe a higher frequency if this a
sound a higher pitch this guy since the
each crest or the cycles are getting
spread out he's going to see them less
frequently less frequently and if this
is sound he's going to observe a lower
pitch